an image of normality turned
upside down like a giant scrapyard
abandoned cars block a tunnel in central
zhongzhou
roads transformed into rapidly flowing
rivers
where in some areas boat is the only way
to get around
the city's inhabitants are used to
typhoons but they're still coming to
terms
with the scale of this week's deluge it
was the heaviest rainfall in 60 years
on tuesday more than 200 millimeters
fell
in just one hour on state tv
the images have been more uplifting
rescuers bringing young and old to
safety
some of the estimated 800 000 residents
who've been displaced
the emphasis is on the positive work
being done
not on those who've died
our teams have rushed to many places we
are carrying out tasks like blasting and
flood diversion
flood fighting and rescue as well as
mass evacuations
the underlying message the party will
protect you
on social media though there's anger at
why local weather forecasters
fail to warn residents properly the city
lies in a flood prone area
the provincial government reportedly
spent more than eight billion dollars
building defenses that were supposed to
prevent
disasters like this happening now
more extreme weather is threatening the
area a typhoon is bearing down
on china's eastern coast and could make
landfall
this weekend adrian brown al jazeera
hong kong